hi Samuel lives here and I wanted to
talk today a little bit about some of
the tax changes coming in and should you
be buying your property your next
property through a limited company or
should you just be behind get as an
individual so that's what we're gonna be
talking about just in the next couple of
minutes firstly let me just give you a
quick introduction to some of the
potential new tax changes that they're
bringing in and why I think that they
are bring them so the government
realized that oh my gosh
property investors are making an
absolute killing hmm we want to slice of
the pie so they're changing some of the
rules slightly and it's basically gonna
eat out of investors profits now some of
the landlord's exist today I'm gonna be
financially crippled some are gonna be
absolutely thawing as we are
professional investors we're gonna be
absolutely fine so the first thing I'll
say is don't worry about some of the the
hearsay around the changes that they're
bringing in one of the legal changes is
the stamp duty changes you have to pay a
lot more stamp duty now on properties
which is annoying there are always
around it if you bind like six
properties at time three limbs you come
to me and things like that but I think
the best thing to do on the stamp duty
changes is just accept you know what
you've got to pay stubs you take and
because you're hopefully buying a
property that's going to be giving you a
high nice income each month you'll have
paid off that stuns you in a couple of
months anyway with the profit that
you're making through your property so
don't worry about it
again as they always say when everyone
else is scared and hesitant that's the
time to be greedy when everyone's greedy
that's the time to be scared the stamp
do changes the tax changes their walls
are all my goodness oh my goodness get
in there now it's the time so some do
they yeah pain get over it
tax changes let me just give you an
introduction to what the changes are
what they're saying is that at the
moment if you rent out a property and
say the rent is six hundred pounds and
your mortgage payment it's four hundred
pounds you're left with a profit of two
hundred pounds each month and that two
hundred pounds is what you would pay tax
on okay now of course you don't pay tax
on the first
eleven thousand pounds that you earn or
whatever is but if you're you know
that's effectively like works you pay
tax on the profit what they're
potentially bringing in and they're
saying that their plan is to phase it in
in M so that it comes in properly in
2020 but what they're saying is that you
no longer can claim your mortgage
expense as a tax-deductible expense hmm
which means that if your wenting a
property up for six hundred pounds and
your mortgage is 200 so four hundred
pounds
you're still got to pay tax on the whole
six hundred pounds now firstly I'll say
I think that is a ridiculous law it's
the only time in the economics of
history in England certain way whereby
you could potentially pay more tax than
you earn because I mean if you're if
your mortgage is six independent than
your rent sticks and did you're making
nothing but you still pain taxed so it's
a ridiculous law I don't even know if
it's gonna come in on up because I'm
kind of thinking it's so stupid the guy
that brought Gloria is now no longer in
his position anymore
there's uproar amongst hundreds and
hundreds and thousands of investors and
landlords and it's gonna Altima tech the
ten more so than the landlord's I don't
know if it's gonna come in or not
but if it does come in what's gonna
happen well the first thing that's gonna
happen is rents will go up because
they're gonna be so many landlords that
oh I can't I can't afford to I was
relying on the income and now I think by
tax more tax so they can i push rents up
now rents haven't gone up really front
from from the era of like 2006 to 2013
rent did not move over the last couple
years they've gone up a bit certainly on
some of the big properties you could you
could like rent a mansion before in the
Midlands for about fifteen hundred
pounds today you're talking at least two
thousand two hundred you know the the
rents have gone up but not so much
amongst the smaller properties all the
rooms so my prediction is I think that
whether the tax changes coming or not
the tax changes will help it I think is
going to push rents up so I'm quite
excited about that so that's one thing
I'll say also it might not come in
if it does come in it's not gonna affect
people like me and you that much why not
well because if our mortgage is four
five hundred pounds and I rent is six
hundred pounds
we're gonna be really effective because
we're gonna have to certainly pay tax on
six a whole lot and the big the big fat
mortgage expense that we were claiming
we can no longer claim as tax deductible
an expense however if you're buying the
property that's cheap for like a hundred
grand or hundred twenty grand and your
mortgage is just a couple of hundred
pounds and your rent is like fifteen
hundred pounds
if you can't claim if you can't claim
that little two hundred pounds and
expense how much is it gonna affects you
thirty pound a month so the new tax
changes are probably really only going
to affect you by about thirty pound per
month per property and they've scared
everybody else off and the pushed rents
up so really is it all that bad
I'm not sure what it is if it comes in
even so I don't think it's really
anything to worry about now there is a
way around it like there always is
because you know what the people that
make the rules make money in property so
there's always ways around that things
like this so I think that one of the
ways around this is to buy properties
through a limited company if you buy a
property three millimeters company you
suck the rules don't apply to you you
can still always claim the the mortgage
payments as a tax-deductible expense so
a lot of people are now setting up
companies and buying through their
company now the question is it a bit of
a nightmare to do that it used to be but
now today because as one rule changes
and becomes more difficult another opens
over here there's an old saying that
says as one door closes another opens
so just allow that they've made they're
making this potential change for the tax
changes they've suddenly made it a
doddle to buy properties through a
limited company you can set up a limited
company tonight for about twelve pounds
and it might take you 15 20 minutes to
do it and then you can buy a property
tomorrow through that company how well
because what they do is they used to
look at the limited company and they
used to say all right well let's do
checks on the company and how much
the company making it was all about the
company today it's not the company can
be a virgin company brand-new set up
what they do is they look at the MD of
the company so as long as you can get a
mortgage you will act as a guarantor for
the company makes sense so what you want
to do is you want to make sure that the
company in fact if the company is an old
company that's been trading is actually
more difficult if you're planning on
buying a property through a company you
wanted to set up a brand new company
with the sole purpose of that company to
buy houses it's really easy to do it
costs about twelve pounds to actually do
it you might want to pay an accountant a
little bit extra to actually do it for
you so should you be buying properties
to manage cumberly I would say probably
yes if you're planning on building a big
portfolio it would make sense if you
just start in our buddy should first
property and you just you know you just
want to sort of trial it and see how it
goes it might be better to just buy it
as an individual reason being is if
you're setting up a company you're gonna
have to set it up you might have to pay
someone to do it or do it yourself
you're then gonna have to do pay an
account one or do it yourself but ya
gonna have to like treat it as a
business and you guys to pay still wants
to do your accounts and things like that
so I'm gonna be expensive but for the
sake of losing a few pounds a month
potentially from doing it as an
individual all I think if you just die
now I'd probably say you know what just
buy as an individual if you if you
really want to be growing this you want
to buy lots of properties then yeah set
up a limited company if you want help
doing that speak to an accountant if you
email me and you're interested I can
give you the details of my accountant
but if you just don't know I'd probably
say do it as an individual
it's your call hope that's been helpful
and look forward to speaking to you real
soon thanks